foreign
demo of how we can do Bitcoin
predictions using machine learning
before we start I hope this screen is
clearly visible and the audio is fine if
yes please type in yes if there are any
issues let us know in the chat section
so that we can resolve them I'm
repeating again before we start I hope
your skin is clearly visible and the
audio is fine
let us know in the chat section so that
we can resolve them let's wait for some
more minutes to let other people join
until then let me tell you guys that we
have regular updates on multiple
Technologies if you are a techie and a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
I think we can get started but we will
write the command to open Jupiter
notebook so here I will write Jupiter
notebook
press enter
open
take in time
Jupiter notebook is open so here I will
go to python3
just here I will write Bitcoin
so let's import some like needed
libraries for this project
but contradiction project
so here I will write import
numpy
then I will write import
pandas
as
I will set the style
as white grid
okay
thirdly
dot Pi plot
as PLT
and I will write pnt dot Style
used
basically one of the style in it
before some major from Keras
sequence
go in detail so stay
on
early stopping
and from get us
yes
support
which is dense lstm
or SK learn
Dot
okay
press enter let's see
is not found
found in the library style libraries and
input is not valid or URL password
if
it will work
okay still loading
let's create
callbacks import or disturbing as
should be capital
so
the library is used for working with
arrays it also has a function for
working in the domain or linear algebra
and matrices it is an open source
project and you can use it freely
by stand for numerical python
and the second one is pandas
so pandas is a software Library written
for the Python programming language for
data manipulation and Analysis in
particular it offers data structure and
operation for manipulating numerical
tables and The Time series
seabon an open source python liability
based on method is called C1
it is utilized for data exploration and
data visualization with data frames and
the pandas Library c bond function with
ease
then this matplotlib
Python and its numerical extension numpy
but broadly Visa like cross platform
data visualization and graphical
charting package as a result it
represents a strong open source
substitute for Matlab the API is for
Matlab allow programmers to incorporate
graphs into like GI applications and all
okay then this lstm
uh lstm stands for long short term
memory layer which created in 1997. this
layer users
available constant and runtime Hardware
to gain the most optimized performance
where we can choose the various
implementation that is pure tensorflow
or you can use solute DJI okay
tense a dense is a layer that is deeply
connected with the preceding layer which
means the neurons of the layer are
connected to every neuron of its page
setting here this layer is most commonly
used
and in the artificial Network neural
networks okay
you can see
they are list of it
okay
only stopping is a form of
regularization
used to avoid overfitting when training
a learning with an iterative method such
as gradient descent
so search method update the Learners so
as to make it better fit the training
data with each iteration
okay
so
this min max scalar min max scalar
transforms feature by scaling each
feature to a given range this estimator
scales and translate each feature
individually such that it is in the
given range on the training data okay
that is like between 0 to 1.
let's move forward and update the
reading data let's read the data so for
that I will write
like data
LM VTC
you can download this file from the
description box below
okay
and you can also comment for the full
code
and that is on the comment section
I will provide you the all the code
DF
first one
here PD is for like pandas library and
read is for reading the data CSV is the
file type
okay so let's see the
data first so for that I will write TF
dotted
EF dot head is used to show the top five
rows of the particular data set
okay but you want to see the last five
rows you can use
tail
and set up
okay these are the five last five tools
these are the last five rows okay got it
foreign
[Music]
function
for the data set so I will write here DF
Dot
all the information about the data set
okay here you can see the we have column
name and name currency date closing
price
24 hour open and then high price low
price
okay then here you can see the number of
value 2787 in particular column
and here you can see no null count here
and data type you can see here a name is
in integer and this currency and data
object
yeah object one and the
these four are the float one okay so
here
gives all the information about
desert
so moving forward
Dot describe
so what described do describe show you
all the statical like value from the
data set for the particular column okay
that count number is like 2787 the mean
of unnamed
column is 1393 and that's standard
deviation then minimum value is 0 then
what is the 25 percent of particular
column so it is like the maximum value
so this is for the all the columns
one two three four five okay
moving forward let's set date column as
an index
for that I have to write a date TF
time
foreign
X
8.
so what I would like to
control y because 2 because you have to
like you want to change in the
particular data okay
let's enter
but let's see the opening and closing
prices of Bitcoin using a graph okay
that I have to write PLT Dot
yeah okay
configure size
equals to
10 point sorry okay
then DF
report
and same for this one also
okay so I have to add one
so here I will write
itself let's set the Y level TLT dot y
level
dot title
in
foreign
open price
can be done type
let's go in there
working or not I don't know
guys
as you can see the opening and closing
price
okay
or the particular bitcoin price of the
Bitcoin
let's move forward
and let's see the high and the low price
of the Bitcoin in the 24 hour
okay
so that I will write PLT dot because
the
size
in comma 6.
yeah
so like
David so let me copy from here
because the thing will be almost same
I have to change here
guys and
yeah
I can write
I and
here I have to write High Press low
price
okay so let me see so as you can see the
high price and the low price of the
Bitcoin in 24 hour okay the blue one
represents the high price and the
Redmond represent the low price
okay
so moving forward let we will do the
data program
data preprocessing okay that's true data
people pre-processing and let's choose
the prediction column
first so for that I will write an
underscore calls equals to
one
then data set
so DF
please
data set
plus two
Dot
data frame
data equation
data set
Dot
data dot shape
so
after this we will do the normalizing of
the data so for that import from
SQL
already discussed
what is min max scalar okay so moving
ahead we'll write his scalar
to min
Max
underscore range
0 comma
okay underscore data
dot fit transform
P dot ND Dot add-in this is from the
numpy
then data
okay let's press enter
use
so
with the data so what we will do we will
split the like 75 percent data to the
training part and the 25 percent to the
testing part okay
are drained
and
okay
so after that
this is for the training data okay 75
percent size for the testing
again
Ms training size
length of the data is like 100 so 100
minus 75 percent is 25 so test size is
25 percent
inside
okay then again we'll get the size
as you can see two zero nine zero is the
trading data for the training size you
can say and let us size is 697.
going ahead let's see let's train
data equals to scale
and underscore size
10 underscore
as you can see there is like two and
zero nine zeros rows and one column
if
so moving forward let's create training
set
okay for like training set with 60 time
steps so for that X underscore train
ing
equal to 60.
false
equals to one
okay then I will write for I in range
meaning
data
and then X
then
underscore data
a minus time
and calls
like seeing like quite drained
no
cleaning data
I comma
I comma
if I
is less than equals to
times
paint
underscore train
underscore trend
okay
and why
okay
then press enter
okay training
as you can see the extreme the array
okay
so now we will convert to numpy array
testing to numpy array so X underscore
train
ing
comma
NP dot array
so after converting into numpy array
let's reshape the input to like n
samples time steps and the end feature
for that X underscore train
equals to MP Dot
V shape
underscore train
and size should be zero
okay
yeah
so now let's see the size
X
n dot shape
as you can see the X strain is two zero
three zero sixty and column is one
then in white rain there is no
with column so okay there is no like
extension
okay got it so moving forward let's
create the model lstm model
okay
for that uh first we will get the model
structure so for that I will write model
equals to
potential
okay
that's DM
and I will write 50
comma return
okay then input
to X underscore train
dot shape
on
we have lstm
again 64.
1
thank you
friends
what they do
yes
and here I provide
model
if I
either
receive
d
okay
so
as you know LSM is lstm is the stand for
long short term memory layer
okay this layer uses like available
constraint and runtime Hardware to gain
the most optimized performance where we
can choose a various implementation okay
and this tense this dance is a layer
that is deeply connected with the
preceding layer important okay
which means the neurons of the layers
are connected to every neuron of its
like preceding layer this layer is most
commonly used layer in artificial neural
networks okay so these are the number of
layers as you can see 32 16 and 64 and
50.
okay
so here I will write let's see the
summary
of the model
okay these are the parameter then output
shape
yeah
so
moving
okay like fitting the lstm to the
training side
okay we have created this model lstm now
we are fitting into the training set
okay
so for that I will write history
model
dot bit
it's underscore chain
because
and
from box should be 100 so it will take
time
and batch size
question 32. let's say is equal to 32.
one train and then Epoch equals 200
so we can do box 10 or 50
no
this is another model dot with God and
expected key a box
so it will run till uh 100 so it will
take time I will get back to you then
okay it is done as you can see here like
the epoxy is done
so moving forward
what we will do
will
[Music]
it
okay
we will do model evaluation okay so for
this we will create this graph like how
many losses how many books okay so what
I will do I will just
paste it here okay
so yes so this is you can see the losses
okay this is mean squared error
so moving forward let's do the
prediction now finally
so for that
first I will
make it
yeah
first we will like creating a testing
this set with these 16 time steps and
one output like we did for the training
one for that I will write a Time
that's true
okay
and data
foreign
test
why underscore test
foreign
range
test data
that's called test dot again we did for
the training one
before then test data
oops
I
dance
Poland
and underscore
okay then y underscore test dot append
data
Poland and underscore calls okay
so now what we will do we will
underscore test
comma y underscore test equal
test
go
test okay
NP Dot
X underscore test
Code test
uh shape
and zero
okay
one
comma and underscore false
input
okay there is another
test data
append quietest
little plane size sorry my bad
oh let's do X underscore test
excellent
okay comma y
underscore test dot shape
okay so these are the testing
okay for the test is 25 percent
so we'll now get predictions so
predictions predictions
dot predict
now inverse the prediction scaling so
for that I will write predictions
to scalars
Dot
97 column one okay now we will do this
root mean square error so inverse like y
test scaling
so for that I would like to buy
underscore test
was to
killer
Dot
test
okay
would mean
square error so it was so NP Dot
into two
don't
um
one two seven zero point four five
okay
dot sqrtmp dot me while test bias
predictions
okay
here I will write
DD Dot data frame
you can hear that predictions
come on
I can write here like actuals
dot y underscore test
don't flatten
72 I mean
that's
these are the like actuals values
okay
so now we will plot a graph of like
predictions kind of prediction versus
actuals you can say
I will write here PLT Dot figure
so 16 comma six
PLT Dot Plot
X okay
Community Dot Plot
.d.11
enough
is another predictions okay what's the
spelling here
copy it from here itself
you can see the blue one are the
predictions and the actuals are the
those one
now let's see the
and see the visualization of the
predictions with the data
so for that this is the final graph you
can say crane
first
Dot I log
GES
okay
0.1
then test was
a lock
zero
first
then
question
is
should be
comma
six
PLT dot Titan
Bitcoin
[ __ ]
applications
font size was frequently
so let's set the X level and the Y level
dot X label
create comma
Bond side
again
um
thanks plus two
thirteen
and PRP
don't plot
okay
just
hold on line width
and copy
copy
I did for the test
right here
Dot
test
let me copy it from here
oh comma line weight
PLT dot Legend
comma
foreign
let me debug the error as you can see
the training test and prediction values
and the yellow one is prediction this
this is the final output of our this
project
this is the final output as you can see
and if you want this full code you can
comment for the same and if you want to
if you want to download the data set so
you can download from the description
box below I hope you guys understand how
we can predict Bitcoin using machine
learning or deep learning you can say so
you can ask in the comment section below
if you have any queries our team will
respond to you as soon as possible don't
forget to subscribe to our YouTube
channel
and you can check the similar courses
links in the description box below
regarding the machine learning and all
if you want this full code just comment
for the same and thank you so much for
being here if you enjoyed this video
please subscribe to our YouTube channel
and press that Bell icon okay till then
thank you and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here